before we go at the end of the show each
morning we will share something to make
your day a little better and brighter
today we want to tell you about
five-year-old Slater Bushman he is going
home healthy after fighting high risk
neuroblastoma for more than 400 days
doctors and nurses at st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital in Memphis
celebrated the fact that he's
cancer-free with a song look at the
smile on his face
Pattie pediatric oncologist Sarah
Federico led the musical celebration she
says this is why she became a doctor
it's kind of indescribable joy when
you're getting to throw that confetti
and and say pack up your bags get out
the door you don't get chemo anymore it
just doesn't get better than that Slater
will go home to Florida within the next
week that's that's such a good story too
the way to end it indescribable joy yes
I want us all to have that feeling yeah
pretty good group of doctors you know
the doctors hearing a lot of kids that
they wrote a song about it yeah they
sing and cure you that's a pretty good
that's a pretty good tag team
Slater Bushman you go yeah don't need
chemo anymore